recuerdas que quería hacer cuando eras
grande que quería ser de grande cuando
eras niño
yo quería ser científica y estudiar las
estrellas del universo
me apasionaba mis libros de astronomía
pues mis abuelos eran docentes y tenía
una biblioteca enorme y aunque no sabía
leer y no entendía lo que decían me
bastaba con ver las fotografías de las
galaxias los planetas y el universo era
lo que disfrutaba y hasta la fecha nunca
ha usado un telescopio
ahora soy yo tecnólogo así que no estoy
o lo macro sino lo micro aquello que no
podemos ver a simple vista
porque yo tecnología adelantada
universidad la palabra biotecnología me
sonaba retadora me decían que era la
carrera del futuro
y va a ser mi decisión en eso fui
afortunada y mi elección fue acertada
así que ahora me apasiona lo que hago y
me enamora pensar en lo que podría hacer
pensar en que podría curar el cáncer
pensar en que podría revertir los daños
de la contaminación o incluso en que
podría cuidar la seguridad alimentaria
del planeta y lo más importante que
podía rediseñar la vida así me imaginaba
el mundo futuro
en este mundo la tecnología y el planeta
no están peleados porque la tecnología
entiende a la vida y en este mundo
futuro podremos cambiar el color de las
flores
podremos regenerar nuestros órganos
podremos incluso
comer alimentos super nutritivos que no
provienen de un animal o vestir ropa y
que no vienen de una fibra hecha en
animales
para algunos este futuro se encuentra a
500 años
para otros 100
pero para mí ya ha comenzado
y todo gracias a este momento
y a ellos quienes se les amerita haber
descubierto el adn la molécula que
origina todo una cadena de información
que nos dice de dónde venimos y adónde
vamos y bueno el adn se encuentra en
cada célula y si pensamos que cada
célula es como una computadora las
computadoras necesitan de programas para
funcionar que a su vez están hechos de
información un código unos y ceros bueno
para que una célula funcione necesita de
genes muchos y estos genes están hechos
de información genética los unos y ceros
de la vida
y bueno
esto me recuerda
desde que sabemos que el adn fue
descubierto en 1953 que ha pasado
el descubrimiento de la insulina humana
a través de producida por bacterias que
viene a reemplazar a la insulina porcina
dando una mejor calidad de vida para las
personas después sin 2050 años después
de este momento se concluye el proyecto
del genoma humano que ahora se descifra
el código que dio origen al hombre y que
ahora ha traído avances en la medicina
moderna que nos llevan al día de hoy el
día en que podemos borrar pegar eliminar
información genética para tratar
enfermedades como el cáncer
esta es una noticia de este mes sobre un
tratamiento donde se usa una nueva
tecnología revolucionaria crisis pero
que si pensamos que el adn es como un
texto en un documento esta tecnología es
capaz de funcionar como un borrador y
poder corregir los errores que nos dan
con nosotros en enfermedades
esto me recuerda a este momento la
invención de la computadora lo que fue
una revolución tecnológica sin embargo
eran máquinas enormes que solamente
podían ser operadas por sus inventores
ingenieros especialistas después se
fueron haciendo más pequeñas llegan a
internet y todos tenemos la necesidad de
compartir información
esto se logra gracias a la ley de moore
que nos dice que podremos duplicar el
número de los transistores por
microprocesador cada dos años en resumen
los tamaños y los precios disminuyen
lo que ahora podemos tener todos un
smartphone pero qué pasa con la
biotecnología bueno eso es como la ley
de moore pero del adn rock carson nos
dice que ahora podemos secuenciar y
sintetizar adn es decir escribir y
traducir el adn
bajando sus costos por letra
sin embargo la información que ahorita
podemos nosotros compartir acceder a
través de una computadora lo hacemos de
manera eficiente todos los días a través
de nuestro smartphone de nuestro correo
imágenes fotografías documentos que
impasa con la información genética acaso
todos podemos acceder a ella podemos
usarla podemos acceder a la información
genética de otros organismos
solamente los especialistas o las
instituciones pero eso está a punto de
cambiar
es un hecho que la biotecnología
y sigue generando soluciones que antes
eran inimaginables y que las siguientes
generaciones deberán verla como una
herramienta de la vida cotidiana
y esto lo lograremos únicamente a través
de la educación una palabra que tiene
gran peso pero yo hablo de la educación
científica no como la tradicional que
está carente y limitada debemos innovar
en educación a través de experiencias
porque porque el mundo cambia
rápidamente y nuestros modelos de
educación permanecen inmóviles
y ante tanta información que hay no
podemos memorizar todo no podemos
aprender haciendo planes debemos
aprender a usar esta información
para que llegue el momento en que
cualquier persona pueda tener una
experiencia y esa sea la marca que les
genere el aprendizaje
actualmente existen tendencias como
realidad virtual la realidad aumentada
la gamificación así como muchas otras
que lo que buscan es que los modelos de
enseñanza y aprendizajes de la
experiencia para los alumnos y esto se
logró con la computadora nuevamente
en primaria no nos enseñaban a usar la
computadora con planas o con dibujos
teníamos una computadora podíamos
prenderla apagarla usar word powerpoint
después empezamos a programar hasta
llegar al punto en que ahora cualquier
niño podría armar su robot
qué pasa con la biotecnología quienes
están educando en las ciencias de la
vida
debe mencionar que son pocos pero aquí
es que lo están haciendo están cambiando
las reglas del juego
y están las instituciones como
nate ser la revista con mayor impacto a
nivel global que ahora ha generado una
plataforma que se llama site tv que
permite que investigadores alumnos
profesores puedan curar información
información que es de libre acceso y
desde cualquier parte del mundo pueda
tener esta experiencia
después están las empresas como boeing
una farmacéutica de eeuu y qué hacen
ellos ellos hacen medicamentos
medicamentos para enfermedades
crónico-degenerativas que por más de 10
años han implementado un modelo a través
de un laboratorio comunitario para niños
invitan tanto a los padres a los niños a
sumarse a aprender ciencia les ponen la
experiencia de entrar a un laboratorio
realizar un proyecto de investigación y
fortalecer el método científico y ahora
estos niños son las generaciones que
están haciendo nuestros medicamentos
y luego están mis favoritos lo odio
hackers los bio hackers son personas que
hacen ciencia pero no pertenecen a una
academia a una institución oa un centro
de investigación
los vio hackers comparten estos valores
de educar y democratizar y ellos son los
que están cambiando el mundo
pondré el ejemplo de baio que hoy es un
laboratorio comunitario de gioja kers
cuando mencionaba que algún día
podríamos hacer nuestros medicamentos en
casa bueno ellos lo están haciendo a
través del proyecto open insulina un
proyecto colaborativo a nivel global que
tiene la misión de que cualquier persona
en sus casas pueda hacer su propia
insulina porque es un medicamento que ya
lleva casi 50 años
entonces en el mercado como descubierto
y sin embargo únicamente las
instituciones farmacéuticas tienen la
decisión de tomar acción sobre él
luego están vengan chis cuando decía que
podríamos consumir alimentos que no
vendrían de un animal este es el caso de
un queso que se produce de manera
sintética conservando todos los
ingredientes pero no viene de la leche
de un animal
y luego están los yo hackers como andy
una apasionada por la educación que hace
talleres súper locos para enseñar
ingeniería genética a niños
andy se enfrenta a las barreras de la
biotecnología los altos costos para las
tecnologías que se necesitan para llevar
a cabo una plan una práctica y él se
suma al movimiento de du jour ser vaya
hazlo tú mismo con biología y él creó
sus equipos como microscopios como otros
equipos de laboratorios para poder
enseñar a otros a usarlos y hacer
biotecnología en esta práctica se llama
sushi molecular y enseña cómo podría ser
la inserción de genes en una célula
y bueno en el movimiento de georges el
valle permite que la comunidad entregue
la tecnología y la haga accesible y que
cualquiera pueda hacer un microscopio
con el costo de un dólar
estos son escenarios internacionales y
me pregunto qué pasa en méxico
y pienso en ellos yo genera una
asociación civil de monterrey que ha
impactado en la vida de más de 1.300
niños a través de cursos de
biotecnología principalmente niños de
secundarias y niños de escuelas en zonas
vulnerables
y bueno yo les conté que soy yo
tecnólogo que soy hacker pero no les ha
platicado de cuál es mi rol en esta
historia
yo quiero que un día cualquiera pueda
aprender y hacer biotecnología
y para ello quiera poner mi propio
laboratorio
sin embargo no tenía la infraestructura
de trabajo para lograrlo
así que empecé sintió que ahora es un
estado que diseña tecnología de manera
accesible que genera material educativo
y que promueve la divulgación científica
con el fin de hacer el camino para estos
educadores un camino más sencillo
este proyecto empezó como una idea
fuimos a un hackathon y ganamos la
vertical de educación lo que nos
permitió atender nuestros primeros
equipos después nos juntamos con una
comunidad las comunidades de javier
hackers y jóvenes biotecnólogos y nos
sigue motivando a que deberíamos
continuar con esta idea porque no
solamente era un problema para méxico
sino para toda la región latinoamericana
y ahora qué pasa con la idea de
laboratorio no la hemos abandonado
seguimos trabajando en ella y esperamos
que este año sea en tres meses o un mes
podamos abrir el primer laboratorio
comunitario en la ciudad de monterrey
ahora con el fin de que así como yo que
puedo hacer que bacterias brillen en la
oscuridad
ustedes puedan llegar a hacerlo y que
algún día ustedes puedan usar su propia
información genética gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]